[Music]
this is it don't you die on me don't
count on
it if this whole thing ended there were
only two pilots left up in the air it'll
be me and it'll be You Buck today the
eth will be sending up three task forces
that's the largest aom monor ever
assembled in the history of mankind
masters of the air is about a group of
American Airmen who did what was asked
of them it's going to get bumpy hang on
guys despite the chances they were
either going to get killed wounded or
captured I had thought there would be
easy to be in the sky pilot a crew back
ahead there's dangers that you don't
really think about there's more chance
of you dying up there than if you were
down in the trenches these daylight
missions is suicide in the face of
unimaginable Mayhem fight is 12:00 you
have 10 guys open fire let them have it
in a machine trying to keep it in the
air any advice try to stay alive yes sir
when you're in combat you know who
you're fighting for the guy to your left
and the guy to your right they have
nothing but each other and they are able
to conquer anything when they stay
together come on I'm pretty sure that
this is the biggest production any of us
have ever done definitely the hardest
mission accomplished boys but this has
been my dream to do something like this
let alone with the team that made Bandit
Brothers in the Pacific
w
and getting to bring life to these
heroic men realizing how dangerous it
was and The Bravery with which they
bought our freedom that's the privilege
for me and I hope that that's what an
audience
[Music]
receives